foreign
[Music]
thank you
Don the kids over here y'all did a great
job counting me down I forgot I had to
come up here so thank you
hey everyone uh for those that don't
know me and for those of you that do
know me and don't remember my name it's
Miriam nice to see you all I always want
to say good morning
I'm just not like used to going to
church at night even though I've been
here for a year and so I've walked
through the door before and I'm like
good morning
anyone ever done that me and then I'm
anxious and I'm like the type of person
who's doing dishes three days later and
I think about it and I'm like why did I
do that I feel so dumb
um
so
uh I just wanted to obviously welcome
y'all for coming here
um and
um I do have one quick announcement it's
kind of like a three in one announcement
um so just to give you a little bit of a
back story the first time I attended the
table was right about a year ago I came
with my best friend and we came uh to
yes Sarah to the uh Easter Service a
year ago that was our first time I had a
broken foot I was hobbling in and uh it
was it was an incredible experience
um is that your first time too yeah I
remember uh so no it was it was such a a
great time if this is your first time
here if it's your 100th time here
anytime in between we want to welcome
you and we we want you to feel wanted
and valued um just kind of like the way
that I felt when I first attended and
that's going to segue into our
announcement can anyone guess what the
announcement is about
Easter yes
so a couple of dates for you to remember
I obviously have to put it on my phone
so I don't I won't judge all of you have
to write it down so um the first one we
have Palm Sunday on April 2nd uh our
Good Friday service is obviously going
to be on a Friday it's on April 7th at 7
00 p.m here here
and well that's the next part
uh Easter you can wear
pajamas you can wear whatever you want
because Easter service is at 8am here
now here's the thing y'all I live about
an hour away and I will be here so no
excuse okay so I'll probably wake up at
like six o'clock yeah anything for
Easter
um it'll be here we'll provide
continental breakfast coffee uh for you
all it's gonna and it's gonna be a great
time um I can tell you from personal
experience that last year was just so
incredible
um it was so moving for me and I hope
it's going to be the same for you all
um with that I'm gonna pass it over to
Mindy and she's going to lead us into
worship with a prayer thank you all
right thank you Miriam can you guys just
give her a hand I just love having
people from our community get up and
share in any sort so and I know
sometimes it takes a little bit of
courage and bravery so she was a teacher
for many a year and so I told her I was
like this is just a bunch of kids out
here Muriel so
um anyways will you guys go ahead and
stand I'm gonna say a prayer and then
we're gonna jump in
Jesus would you just come and fill up
our hearts with your presence with your
goodness
thank you for the way that you meet us
right where we're at
God thank you for the way that you
anchor us into truth
into Beauty
thank you for breaking through some of
our walls
some of the hard places in our hearts
so that we can receive your love again
God would you meet us here as we sing
as we speak out
things that I believe are true and good
pure and holy
God would it set our minds
on the way that you see us the way that
you want us to interact with each other
with this world
with our struggle with our pain
would it reshape
our story
would it reframe our world view
we just make room for you we give you
space
and I thank you for the people who have
entered into it God and the way that you
make space for each one of us
amen
Gary's going to get us started with the
father's house and I think the words
kind of say it all on this one so we'll
just let you take it
[Music]
thank you
sometimes on this journey
get lost in my mistakes
[Music]
my story isn't over my story's just
begun
fear you won't you find me that's what
my father does I feel you won't Define
me that's what my father does anymore
[Music]
you're in the father's house
the Bible's not the end game the
Journey's where you are you never want
it perfect you just wanted my heart and
the story isn't over you story isn't
good figures
[Music]
your burdens down
let's come home
Love Is On The Move when the father's in
the room
those like why
why the dead come to life
Love Is On The Move when the father's in
the room
Miracles take place
[Music]
Love is
in the room
[Music]
welcome anymore
thank you
all right thank you Gary you kiddos are
dismissed to your classrooms and I
believe it's preschool over here and
school-aged kiddos over there
thank you
Kelly
who else is working tonight
Anna and Devin thank you guys so much
for taking this time with our kids we
appreciate it
we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people so would you guys
join me and read this aloud
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for those experienced sorry
for the vulnerable and the marginalized
and those unjustly targeted for their
gender sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you Lord we know that
you love us and that you hear us so we
lift these names and situations up to
you
Johnny Owen
[Music]
Jeff
foreign
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
[Music]
this next song talks about how we're
seen by God
how he is not far away from us but
someone who knows us and loves us and
there's this one line that I just wanted
to read before we sing it it says you've
been waiting to show us mercy your
presence is our home
and I love that because it reframes I
think for many of us
that view of God that we may have held
that's like the Angry God waiting to get
onto US waiting for us to fail waiting
uh to condemn us or you know
come down on us with some judgment from
above but instead if we can reframe this
view of God as this one who is there
waiting with Mercy awaiting with
kindness ready for us to experience love
and new life that's a completely
different God that's a completely
different way to interact with the
Divine it's a completely different
stance whenever I come into prayer or
whenever I take space to read the Bible
or have a conversation with a friend
when I'm imagining and expecting a God
who meets me with his love who meets
others with his love not his judgment
so I just invite you guys to open up the
framework of your mind and maybe see God
in a new way if that's helpful As we
sing foreign
[Music]
we've been
wondering
in the darkness
but if we own we knew
you are known as
[Music]
sing that again we are known
we are known in love
[Music]
we are known
and loved by you
[Music]
've been waiting
to show us mercy your presence is our
home
we're your children
love forever
now every fear s
[Music]
by you
there is no fear anymore
cause all that's left is Mercy
there is
[Music]
there is no fear
cause all that's left is Mercy
there is no
fear in
love
[Music]
we are known in love
by you
yes
[Music]
thank you
you surround me with a song
of Deliverance
from my enemy
to all my fears are gone
[Music]
longer
girl's name to fear
when I am a child
of God
for my mother's womb
you have chosen me
[Music]
I've been born again
into your family
[Music]
foreign
I am a child oh god let's sing that one
more time I'm no longer I'm no longer
[Music]
I am a child
God
oh
Lord
[Music]
IES
my fears are drowning perfect you
[Music]
you excuse me
life is a drowning perfect love
[Music]
you rescued me
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you and I'm no longer
a Slave To Fear
[Music]
I am a child of God
I'm no longer
Slave To Fear
I am a child
of God
[Music]
I am a child of God
fully loved and fully known
Jesus thank you
for the way that you call us into your
family
for the way that you've adopted us
that the character and the nature of
Jesus runs through our blood
that your spirit is part of us
that you are closer than our heartbeat
thank you for creating us for love
that we can choose to walk in that
over shame over fear
over addiction or Brokenness
or any struggle God that your love is
stronger
would we allow that to claim us
to name us
to write our story
you are good
you are kind and faithful
you are forgiving and gracious
and you are just and right and true
[Music]
thank you God
for who you are
and would we find ourselves in that
would you anchor us in
ground Us in at God
in your name I pray
amen
thank you guys so much you can go ahead
and turn to the people around you
welcome them make them feel at home and
then we'll get seated and start with our
message
all right
Grace and peace
it is so good to be with you all there I
am
so so good to be with you all
um and I want to just welcome welcome
you here to the table and uh that
includes those joining us online you are
not forgotten that you might be at a
little bit of a distance
um not forgotten and uh yeah it's just
it's really really good to be with you
we are um in the season of course of
Lent this 40 day
time of spiritual preparation as we
approach uh Good Friday the day the
cross and then
um on to Easter Sunday I do I encourage
you to be with us during that kind of
Holy Week time it sort of kicks off like
Mary mentioned April 2nd Palm Sunday
um and then kind of goes into you know
everything with Good Friday and Easter
and
um yeah it's going to be I think really
really just a beautiful service I love
Palm Sunday if you were here last year
like we started last year was our first
time to do it we're like going for it
we're like palm branches wait not just
the kids some communities do like well
let the children act a fool and kind of
walk around to do you know no not here
at the table we're like everyone all
participation you know I mean we're just
like Hosanna Jose I mean it's fantastic
um and so I do it I encourage you to be
here um for that just that whole week I
think will be really beautiful so um
we uh we are in a series right now
titled lint the way of the Cross we're
just we're just reflecting week after
week on um on the cross and so the the
title of my message tonight is the cross
and the powers the cross and the powers
um I want to start with another quote uh
from Fleming Rutledge she's been very
familiar to you all throughout this
series I wasn't lying when I said I was
going to draw on flaming religion you
vote her three times the sermon you're
like I know I know I am uh it's really
it's just her book the crucifixion was
was so impactful on me um so she said
this
God's justification of Sinners that just
means you know the setting right
of sinners
God's justification of Sinners is not a
forgetting
right it's in other words not just like
a wife like oh I don't even see I don't
even see what she did you know we're
just like trying to wipe away like oh
what sin wasn't I don't see anything you
know like it's not it's not a forgetting
um and she says nor is it simply
forgiveness so she's not saying it's not
forgiveness no it is but it's it's not
only that
it is a definitive
wholesale final assault upon and defeat
of sin understood as a power in the
creation of a new Humanity can I get an
amen that's I mean can you see where
it's sort of like she's she's trying to
say it's it's more than that you know
it's not less than that it's not she's
not she's not saying forgiveness but
it's just it's it's like in other words
we often kind of reduce the cost you
know
um this also really opens it up to where
it's it's not only just about like you
know me and my soul you know and I
better make sure I'm right with Jesus
you know it's like okay well it's not
less than that but it is more than that
I mean even her language of the creation
of a new humanity and you can tell like
whoa okay this is sort of a big deal
this is big and social
um and public uh so okay so where is
Rutledge getting this idea uh well it's
all over the New Testament
um I'm gonna give you three examples
um from uh one from Colossians and then
two from Ephesians so we'll start with
the the passage in Colossians says and
having disarmed the powers and
authorities he made a public spectacle
of them
triumphing over them by the cross you
can notice how Paul sort of reverses it
here like in our minds this makes
perfect sense like oh yeah of course
Jesus was so Victorious on the cross you
know but you can see where from like a
first century perspective it's like I'm
sorry what
Victorious on the cross or arrested
executed
Victor you know now of course A lot
changes in line of Resurrection
um but
you can see where Paul's sort of
reversing it like in other words the the
principalities in the powers
um you know capital e evil itself
thought to do what to Jesus thought to
humiliate him shame him defeat him take
him down and then what's Paul naming
what happened
this great reversal right where all of a
sudden it's Christ who's elevated and
it's it's he's saying through the cross
actually he made us a public spectacle
of them triumphing over them by the
cross another example this is from
Ephesians 2. once he says right into the
church there you were dead because of
your Disobedience and your many sins
used to live in sin just like the rest
of the world obeying the devil the
commander of the powers there's that
word again in the Unseen World
he is the spirit at work in the hearts
of those who refuse to obey God so you
can kind of hear this
um you know you can hear where it's more
than just kind of an individual soul or
or like oh did you sin you know it's
like there's a bigger thing going on a
bigger battle so to speak and then a few
chapters later uh it's my last example
from Ephesians 6. for we are not
fighting against flesh and blood enemies
boy we need to remember that one church
because how quickly do we forget which
we'll unpack more in just a second but
against two evil rulers and authorities
you say oh exactly but where does he go
of the Unseen World against Mighty
powers in this Dark World against evil
spirits in the Heavenly places I think
this matters because
um
well I think one thing we need to keep
in mind when we start talking about uh
you know Christ as Victorious this can
lead to what I might call a uh a kind of
muscular Christianity to put it
metaphorically like this sort of well we
are the through Christ of course but we
kind of quickly forget that through
through Christ we are victorious and the
church shall overcome and Prevail over
all of her enemies and we know who her
enemies are aren't we and someone's like
the Unseen powers and the spiritual
they're like no those people those
you know what I mean like it's it sort
of becomes this uh and of course it
changes you know through the centuries
who we're talking about sort of shifts
in changes uh but a feud I jotted down
Muslims you know so in other words any
sort of people often it's um depending
on your part of the world the religious
other will sort of shift and change you
know so it could be Muslims or um
atheists or or in the political realm it
could be um Communists or fascists or
Democrats or Republicans or you know
socialists or or really kind of come
back to religion kind of fundamentalists
of any type you know because it's easy
to see
um no matter what wing of the church we
find ourselves in we can always find a
way to you know have our enemy and you
can see where again what I'm trying to
name here is how we start to use the
cross and the Victorious language you
know Christ the Victor he's the Victor
over the powers and you know you can see
where that sort of rhetoric all of a
sudden Slips Away From Where what Paul's
naming so that's what I want to bring us
back to we're not we're not fighting
against flesh and blood
um so I'm kind of uh let me just go
ahead and kind of transition into some
some a few implications of this that I
want to draw some of them have already
kind of named but um I just want to kind
of tease some of these out tonight so if
you're a note taker I've got four four
kind of implications of this for you
um so implication number one the powers
the powers refer to capital S sin not
lowercase s sins you could also say um
capital e evil like I mentioned earlier
not like lowercase e the individual
misdeeds and evil things that we do
um so I think y'all are already kind of
tracking that from the verses but just
to make it
um really really clear and um in other
words there's sort of uh and I want
belabor this point too much because I
feel like I've touched on it probably
two or three times in the last like four
months
um but there's there's kind of a a
behind working behind the scenes
um in history there's certain forces
that are trying to pull less towards bad
ends uh I was thinking of like a
contemporary example
a few years ago I watched episode one
and only episode one because I found it
too disturbing of
um conversations with a killer the Ted
Bundy tapes oh some of y'all are into
the True Crime stuff
I can't do it and I've heard some people
like to listen to the podcast people
who before bed
before the sleepy time
I don't know there's a fascinating
psychology to all this that I don't get
okay anyway back to this disturbing
thing so I only watched episode one
partly because I just found it
personally disturbing I'm like okay I
already struggle with anxiety in this
world so I don't know if I need this
um but second it was at least this
episode kind of seemed almost kind of
glorify him and I'm just like I don't
know not a fan and so anyway
um but I was I did make it through the
episode though and so there's a few
things so it's conversations right so
it's literally like a news reporter got
accessed and had all these recorded
conversations and you get to hear clips
and stuff and I was struck like when I
was um
think of this message like some of the
language that uh Bundy was using
um he used the language uh and just for
those unfamiliar Ted Bundy I think you
mostly just a bad guy murdered I mean
just bad like 30 women and maybe others
you know just a disaster
um so but he was using this language he
talked about um he kept referring to
this entity this Malignant Force
um he said he had this voice in his head
instructing him what to do
and I think it's that which we could
just write off to like just it was
mental illness it was maybe maybe
there's more though you know
um something else going on in fact I
found a quote from his former girlfriend
she's actually the one who eventually
turned him in and told the police I
don't know for sure but you need to
um
yeah I was just sort of disturbing you
know in his own right she but she said
this he told me he was sick and he was
consumed by something that he didn't
understand that he just he couldn't
contain it he spent so much time trying
to maintain a normal life and he just
couldn't do it he said he was
preoccupied with this Force
and so you can hear
um and and maybe you're you're not
you're like I don't know if I go in for
the whole Angel's demons thing and just
you know okay fair enough I'm you know
I'm not gonna like argue but um I I
think there's something to it
um and maybe it's not as simplistic as
we sometimes think of it or like I don't
know with winged creatures there's I
don't know but I do think there's
there's something pulling Humanity at
times towards bad ends just like I think
there's
um someone uh pulling us towards the
good and the Beautiful and the true and
the christ-like towards love right and
you can kind of see where we are when we
battle this on a daily basis this sort
of upward pull in this downward tug you
know and it's like oh we feel it like in
our heart and soul um bring coming back
to Rutledge again sin is not so much a
collection of individual misdeeds
as it is an active malevolent agency
bent on despoiling imprisonment and
death the utter undoing of God's
purposes misdeeds right in other words
like sins or doing wrong things are are
signs they're signs of that agency at
work but they are not the thing itself
it's the thing itself that is our Cosmic
enemy
um so you can see this kind of starts to
draw out the the idea of the the powers
and these unseen forces and really what
we're kind of talking about
um so okay second implication of of the
Cross and the powers is that the world
this means the world is not neutral
territory it's actually enemy occupied
territory now I realize this could be
kind of pulled so extreme like and don't
worry you're not going to hear me like
starting to preach I'm gonna do a whole
series on this 10 weeks and then we all
get super paranoid and we're like
there's demons around every corner and
you know I don't know we start
Discerning everyone's like she's got the
spirit of stuff you know when you start
getting judgy and weird and okay I'm not
trying I'm not trying to do that but I
think in
there's I think could be an opposite
problem you know where it's sort of like
huh what no there's nothing no problems
around you know what I mean and so I
don't want us to be that kind of church
either you know
um and so I think it's helpful just to
remember like even how Jesus life just
began I found this um passage you
remember I mean he's born into this
world and right from the very beginning
his life is in danger this is um Matthew
2 you have uh Jesus and then Mary and
Joseph as parents in this the text says
this when they had gone an angel of the
Lord appeared to Joseph his father of
course in a dream get up he said take
the child and his mother and escape to
Egypt stay there until I tell you for
Herod is going to search for the child
to kill him so you can see where right
it's not that Jesus came to the world
and the world rejoiced and it's like yes
this is our Our Savior and the Son of
God you know no it's like right from the
very beginning there's the battle to
fight here there's certain forces in the
world that want to Snuff that child out
and quickly the quicker the better
uh and so of course a lot of Jesus sort
of growing up ears are like a mystery to
us we don't the Bible doesn't include a
lot of detail
um but then he grows up and right from
the beginning you'll recall just the
sake of time I won't read the whole
story but uh he start just to begin his
ministry he's called into the Wilderness
right where he's tempted by who
the devil right and yeah the adversary
and this
this becomes right it sort of frames his
ministry and then uh the way Luke tells
the story he leaves the Wilderness where
he's been tempted by the devil
and then almost immediately this happens
um
he returns to the city so from the
desert into the City and then says this
Luke 4 in the synagogue there was a man
possessed by a demon by an impure Spirit
he cried out at the top of his voice go
away what do you want with us Jesus of
Nazareth have you come to destroy us I
know who you are the Holy One of God
be quiet Jesus said sternly come out of
him and then the demon threw the man
down before them all and came out
without injuring him so these are just I
mean I could give you like if you've
read the New Testament and specifically
the gospels you know it's just like
story after Story of this sort of thing
um happening so
um all right so that's our second
implication third implication the powers
corrupt not only individuals but through
them human institutions
uh in other words never forget that like
how is Jesus crucified it was under the
watchful eye of of religious leaders and
political leaders
uh that put him to death and this this
says something to us um one way I might
sum it up would be this though ordained
or intended and ordained by God for good
uh human institutions and I'm thinking
here I just wrote down all the ones I
could think of I wasn't trying to like
be early specific just give you a I mean
all of them
um governments and universities and
corporations and media outlets and Banks
and labor unions and yes even churches
have fallen into the grip of the powers
of sin and death
um now does this mean it's sort of oh
well then just do away with them all and
then all their problems will be solved
of course the trick is whatever replaces
them does what
comes under the sway of the
principalities and the powers
um and this becomes a a real problem I I
thinking of coming back to churches
because I really want to be careful I'm
not just I don't know poking at all the
other institutions out there like oh can
you believe them you know and then sort
of smugly right at that moment of Pride
what's happening
you're like falling and understand I
mean like I was thinking about this the
the table churches obviously it's like a
small but it is you know a like in a way
I'm I'm like the the point leader at the
top of like a little hierarchy you know
I mean and of course we have our Elder
teams that don't just like do whatever
I'm not tired but you know what I mean
but it's there's it's leadership right
and not everyone has the same voice you
know what I mean and I was thinking like
how foolish would I be
to be like oh well I'm you know
a pastor and this is a spiritual
community and so the the principalities
and the powers they could never hold the
way here I mean like is there not if
you've ever LED anything is there not a
voice that sort of tempts you like hey
use it to your own advantage
you know like especially I think pastors
really struggle with this probably
because of all the talking and the
microphones and such and I think it's a
real ego thing that can happen you know
of like um you know they're they're here
to to
um to build your kingdom you know I mean
you can see where this becomes a
tremendous problem uh in church
communities and so uh oh Lord have mercy
may I never
start down that road you know and or at
least be aware of if it ever begins to
happen
um
another example I was thinking of was
um and this does kind of relate directly
to the table at times I know people have
wondered
um why
um we aren't and even my messages and
things I'm I'm not super patriotic
you know like around Fourth of July and
stuff I'll tend like not to do like uh
you know I mean I don't know God Bless
America and that kind of thing
um and I think it could be misread like
oh he must be so embittered in America I
think it's the worst country in the
world it's not that I I mean I've born
and raised here I really appreciate and
love this country it's there is so much
good here
um but
can you hear we're in light of
everything we've named
a certain naive kind of embrace
of love of country can absolutely get
you in trouble and get whole churches in
trouble right where it just it becomes
um well as I've mentioned before like
where you kind of end up collapsing the
kingdom of God into love of country and
there's almost one in the same we are
the city set on a hill as Jesus said you
know and it's sort of like wait who's
the Wii you're talking about you know
well of course America you know it's
like well we've gotta I think we've got
it we've got to be wiser in our
uh the way we relate partly because it
is probably at that precise moment that
we just might be falling under the sway
of the principalities and
um yeah in the in the powers uh so
fourth and final you are ready for some
good news I realize it's been a little
you know
um
fourth the cross has delivered a fatal
blow to the powers
in the cross we see the in-breaking of
God's New Age into the old age of a new
era into the old era and that old regime
it was characterized since Cain and Abel
by violence and cruelty greed and
avarice disease and death but it has
through the cross and resurrection of
Jesus been pushed back the decisive
battle has been fought though clearly I
mean you can just look at the world the
war so to speak the spiritual war again
spiritual we're talking about
um is is clearly not
um not over and can you see
uh that through this like it starts to
clarify our mission
um that that what are we called to we
are here to shift a generation
from reactionary and what is what does
that mean from from a reactionary
violent
um kind of impulsive
uh
openness to what is not good end of God
and we're here to shift a generation out
of that away from the powers of sin and
evil and we're here to to shift a
generation to call them to invite them
to um welcome them into the liberating
power of God in his son Jesus Christ and
this is a movement that's characterized
not by violence but by peace not by
hatred but reconciliation not by greed
but generosity not by fear but Freedom
not by death but life
close at this story there's a very
famous I mean I'm sure all of you have
maybe not all but many of you have
either read the book or more than likely
seen the movie
um it doesn't so much apply to the
musical but specifically the movie um
from Les Miserables
and there's a famous scene probably the
most famous scene in the whole thing um
it's Unforgettable where you have the X
convict you know Jean Valjean and uh let
you know out of prison honest travels uh
stops and receives the hospitality of a
local Bishop uh who you know welcomes
them in and there's something about you
know welcoming someone into your home
like it's an act of vulnerability
hospitality is always an act of
vulnerability because you think of you
know we have the the windows and the
doors it's almost like a little you know
it's like the city Gates or something to
our our little kingdom our little you
know sort of you invite someone in
and suddenly it's you know and so that's
what happens this bishop in an act of
Christian Hospitality of course invites
Jean Valjean in and as most of you know
what does he do uh he he takes advantage
of the men's Hospitality he he steals uh
some of the silver
he then leaves the middle of the night
he is of course caught uh the soldiers
then drag him back to The Bishop's house
where uh that famous uh kind of
interaction happens where they basically
say like hey so he said that uh this
silver you know that you gave it to him
and uh you know of course he's a liar
you know and so what does the bishop do
right you remember he says that well of
course I did and Jean version how could
you be so foolish you forgot the
candlesticks and he starts like grabbing
more silver and like shoveling it
towards Valjean I mean some just a
genius moment you can tell
um a lot of like Christian themes and
things you know going on there and of
course the soldiers are shocked just
like what is going on
um and I mean what can they do they're
like okay I guess it was an awesome gift
and so they leave and Valjean is
freaking out right because he's like
what are you what is this game what are
you doing right now
and um I think it's at this point that
we kind of in those similar way that we
misread a little bit or make it overly
simplistic our Approach To the Cross
like I said earlier or say I think if we
were to ask like so what just happened
there
we might say well the bishop forgave
Jean Valjean
and it's like
that's true
um but there's this wonderful quote
if you recall what the bishop actually
says to him when Valjean says what are
you doing here uh he says this Jean
Valjean my brother
you no longer belong to evil
with this silver I've bought your what
your soul
I've ransomed you from fear and hatred
and now I give you back to God
can you hear
what's going on there I mean it's
everything we've been talking about it
is the Theology of the cross
this is more than drama Jean you've been
forgiven
this is you have been claimed which is
why Valjean is freaking out because he
can sense it he knows oh no oh no
there's no getting out of this unchanged
this encounter is going to change me
forever right Church like this is what
has happened to each and every one of us
we have yes we've been forgiven but more
than that we have been delivered from
the powers of sin and evil and death
and we have been claimed by the love of
Christ
and what does that mean for us that
means now we go out these doors and we
have been sent
commissioned
to meet other people and through our
words and our actions
to communicate to them that they too
have been claimed by The God Who is love
so
um that's our invitation
tonight to be those kinds of people
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we take in the body of Christ and the
bread
the blood of Christ and the wine
we come to the one who has ransomed us
claimed us
not only forgiven
but has invited us into
his new Humanity into his family
and so I just I encourage you like all
the songs we were singing about the
power of God and no longer being a slave
to sin and no longer feeling that kind
of orphaned spirit because that's what
happens with with
um sin and evil it just it drags us and
it gets us isolated and alone but here
we're brought back close into the family
of God so I encourage you as you come
forward to receive the body of Christ
and the bread the blood of Christ and
the wine that it would be that kind of
powerful
moment for you so um
I think everyone who's here tonight has
taken communion before or at least heard
the Spiel so just know
come forward and you got it you know
what to do don't be surprised by that
wine all right I've told you so many
times I don't know at some point I gotta
stop mentioning it so
uh so let me welcome to the table with
this this invitation
this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you and it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here
to the table
[Music]
good
foreign
[Music]
thank you Caleb and Chris for serving us
so powerful
do you guys stand with us as we sing
this last song We introduced it a few
weeks ago in in the season of lent
it just seems to have a whole different
kind of connection As we sing about the
power of the Cross and now how it claims
us so um
close out with this
[Music]
the cross has the final word
sorrow may come in the darkest night the
cross has the final word
the cross has the fine word
[Music]
evil may put a bit
strongest fight the cross has the
fireworks
[Music]
the cross
who crosses the fight away
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
name of Jesus
all the flowers
[Music]
all the glory to the name of Jesus
the cross
[Music]
the crosses
says
[Music]
foreign
so I just want to thank Brett for such a
beautiful message
for me it reminded me of something that
I grew up with if y'all don't know I
grew up in a very strict religion I grew
up Muslim and
um every day was you know consisted of
feeling like I had to do everything
right or and if I didn't then I had to
work to do better
um
a Christian your sins are forgiven now
that doesn't mean you can do whatever
you want right but the stress and the
pressure that was lifted off of me um
it's just so beautiful
um and I hope if you didn't get
something like that from this message
that you did get something that you
could potentially bring to your life and
how you help other people
um I do want to thank you all for coming
like Brett said it looks like everyone
has potentially been here before but we
thank you for coming anyways um I wanted
to mention that if you need a prayer or
as Don says if you're a high five hug
type of person
um you can come find me I love those
anyone on the worship team I'm sure
would love to do that as well Brett
um
we could all use some hugs and prayers
I wanted to mention this just if there
was anyone new that there are visitor
welcome cards in the back outside of the
sanctuary if you haven't filled out one
before and you would like to for us to
you know just get to know you they're
not gonna bombard you with phone calls
or mail or anything I can attest to that
we would love to be able to pray for you
and have your information so if you can
do that that would be great
lastly I'm gonna send you off with a
benediction I can't promise it's going
to be as great as when Karen does it
when Karen does it it just like I'm just
like like that just feels so nice but
and she hasn't memorized I don't so I'll
read it out for you
um you're all standing so we'll we'll
stay standing if you want to have a
posture of receiving you're welcome to
do that whatever is comfortable for you
um you are a child of God
you are a child of God this is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day so as you go into your week
ahead and it's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you're worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
love compassion and Grace to everyone
that you
we hope you all have a great week
[Music]
nothing greater than the name of Jesus
all the glory to the name of Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
he traded
[Music]
[Applause]